it was on this site 100 years ago
that the worst terrorist attack in
american history up until that point
was carried out at 1201 pm
on september 16 1920
a bomb delivered via dynamites and
horse-drawn carriage
at wall and broad street in lower
manhattan killed
38 people and seriously injured 143 more
within a minute of the explosion which
occurred just outside the offices of
famed financier j.p
morgan trading on the new york stock
exchange was suspended
to prevent a further panic the carnage
was unlike anything america's largest
city had ever seen
and was splashed across headlines for
days as those who survived were treated
the investigation began with an
immediate focus on several radical
leftist political groups
even before the wall street explosion
there had been nationwide raids on
communist headquarters a result of the
general
belief that bolsheviks were plotting to
overthrow the government
anger over u.s capitalism and wealth
inequality had been growing for decades
the anarchists from italy in particular
became the primary suspects
in part it was believed over their
frustration about the imprisonment of
saco and venzetti
two men who'd been erroneously convicted
of murdering a guard and paymaster while
they were carrying out an armed robbery
near boston the year before at first
investigators were puzzled and
considered it not
an act of terrorism since no wall street
businessmen were killed
instead street workers vendors and
clerks
many on their way to lunch it was noted
that the statue of george washington
just across the street escaped unscathed
so to jp morgan who was vacationing in
scotland at the time
eventually attention shifted back to
disgruntled communists and anarchists
with the main focus on mario buddha a
longtime activist
and former associate of saco and
venzetti he left the country not long
after
and in the end no one was ever formally
convicted of this heinous crime
today the only evidence that remains
from that tragic event
are from these shrapnel marks on the
facade of j.p morgan's old building
there was a desire to reopen wall street
as quickly as possible so some believe
that important evidence got washed away
after but think about that we just had
the story about about 9 11 and the men
behind it had not been prosecuted yet
and this crime 100 years ago was never
solved
great piece of history yeah really
fascinating people forget about
yeah thank you